[Music]
first of all I kind of grew up in a
religious environment sort of my dad was
a Presbyterian minister his dad was a
Presbyterian minister I was actually an
altar boy at st. Stephen's Episcopal
Church in Armonk New York I would raise
Episcopalian even though my dad was
president hearing because he was more of
a social worker than a like a pastor and
our mock didn't have a presbyterian
church I myself of men a theist never
really kind of was religious even though
I was raised sort of religious so I
always thought religion was kind of
amusing because it was very benign when
I you know I went to this nice church
and everybody sang hymns and stuff like
that and I didn't exactly you know want
to mock them but I didn't I didn't
really understand why they believe what
they believe in activity they do and so
it sort of I never really wrote a lot
about religion as a humorist
but I always that my sensibility always
was a there's a lot of religions a lot
of people believe a lot of different
things they all think they're right
there's the value of I guess making fun
of that is it's okay to believe whatever
you believe as long as you don't think
that everyone has to believe it and if
you're willing to laugh a little bit
about your own beliefs then it's just
going to be easier for everybody to get
along with with different beliefs if you
are like really rigid about what you
believe then it's going to be you know
there can be a variety of bad
consequences up to and including people
killing each other so the value of
mockery of religion or faith isn't so
much - I don't think put people down
although I guess that's an element in
some humor that not much religion so
much is to say don't take yourself the
too seriously because that could lead to
problems down the road which is kind of
what humor is about with almost every
topic
[Music]
you